come on you had to grow was it a massage
or a beard um I was making a film with
Doug Liman in Montreal and I was playing
a real tough kid and he asked me to grow
as much facial hair as I could which is
really impressive I think we've got a
picture of the amount of facial hair you
get ready six weeks great
cuz how old are you now I'm 23 now yeah
cuz you do look ridiculous to young
thank you so can you make in terms of
getting served and things like that why
have a similar story I was once I went
out to a pub with my mum in Kingston and
we had a phrase Lee says should we go
out clubbing yeah mum if you want we can
as a few clubs in town we go out we'd go
to the door I give them my ID they let
me in and then they won't let my mum in
because she doesn't have ID and I'm
trying to explain to the obviously dumb
bouncer that I came out of her
20-story was in cinemas
I don't know what you guys have been
going but I used to go and get like I
got a fake ID when I was a kid
fortunately yeah that was that was super
easy I went down to the julie julie
district Jewelry District and I just I
got myself a fake ID I could get in
almost almost anywhere but now what was
the name on the fake ID
Jose cervesa knew what I wanted
joe-joe beer I asked for it people know
oh do you ask no don't wear masks for no
they gave you these like crazy names
they were like crazy name they were
trying to get you caught but I didn't
ever get you actually it succeeded yeah
right this way mr. survey
[Applause]
[Music]
you